My name is Afi and I am a student.
>> Afi is a student. Correct. Carry on.
>> I will make it very concise now.
>> Okay. So basically if Allah is God,
if Allah is all powerful, if he's the
powerful, can he be in flesh like Jesus
before? As can Allah be in flesh like be
human like Jesus?
>> Can Allah incarnate? If Allah is all
powerful, can he incarnate in flesh like
Jesus? Okay, I'm not done because I
watch your videos and you say that Allah
cannot do un ungodly thing. Okay, I take
it. But here's the thing,
>> brother.
>> It's logic.
>> I keep on asking asking asking.
>> We are running short of time.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Question should be three or four
sentences.
>> Okay.
>> Your question is can Allah become human
being in flesh? The answer is no. Allah
does not do ungodly things.
Quran says in surah nisa chapter 4 verse
number 40 Allah is never unjust in the
least degree. Allah cannot tell a lie.
Allah cannot do injustice. Or you can
say Allah will not do injustice. Allah
will not become a human being. Whichever
you prefer. So Allah only does godly
things.
He cannot he will not do ungodly thing.
Now some people say oh don't say the
word Allah cannot do okay. Say Allah
will not okay. Allah will not. Some
people feel bad.
They say, "Oh, how can you say Allah
cannot do so and so?"
They said, "You should say Allah will
not do." Choice of words.
The logic if it's strong. So some
Muslims they prefer you say Allah will
not do. Okay. Allah cannot do, Allah
will not. If you're happy with that,
I'll say Allah will not become a human.
Both the cases never will you find Allah
becoming a human being. Hope that
answers the question.